>> So let's see how measures of center change when we have different
distributions. On this positively skewed distribution, which do you think is
true? Do you think the mean is less than the median, which is less than the
mode? Or do you think the mean is the greatest, and the median is the smallest?
Or do you think the mode is less than the median, is less than the mean? Or do
you think the median is the greatest and the mode is the smallest? Now remember,
on the x axis, we go from least to greatest. So, on this distribution, think
about where the mean, median and mode would lie on the x axis, and choose which
one of these you think is true. This is a really difficult question that
requires you to think about everything we've talked about so far, how the median
and mode are not affected as much by outliers as the mean, how the mode is not
affected by outliers at all, and how the median will barely change if an outlier
is added. Give it your best shot.